[موسيقى]
فرص المعتقلين السياسيين امام القضاء قد
تبدو الاجابه بسيطه في الظروف العاديه
فحظوظهم وافره جدا في اثبات البراءه نظرا
لان ملفاتهم فارغه تماما
وهي ولكن في الظروف الحاليه والخلفيه
السياسيه الكيديه لهذه القضايا فليس هناك
امر مضمون للايقاف ومبرر ولا الافراج
يستند الى ادله واثباتات فالامر لا يعود
القاضي وانما يعود الى الاراده السياسيه
[موسيقى]
التبريرات وخاصه
التهمه العاديه التي توجهها الانظمه
الاستبداديه الى معارضها وهي التامر على
امن الدوله الداخلي والخارجي علما بان
النيابه العموميه ذاتها التي وجهت
الاتهامات هي التي برات المنطقه السياسيين
بشكل غير مباشر لانها برات الدبلوماسيين
الاجانب وبالتالي فتهمه التخابر والتامر
مع هذه الاطراف الاجنبيه لم يعد لها وجود
مادي تبعا لتبرئه هؤلاء وبالتالي تعتبرات
السلطه تبقى كلها تمريرات وهي لها
[موسيقى]
السلطه القضائيه في تونس لا يمكن ان نقول
انها قادره على الصمود في وجه السلطه
التنفيذيه هناك فقط
قضاه يحاولون الصمود
وفي وجه الحمله الشعواء غير المسبوقه التي
قامت بها السلطه التنفيذيه اتجاه القضاء
وخاصه بحل السلطه العليا في القضاء وهي
المجلس الاعلى للقضاء ثم بحمله غير مسبوقه
من اعفاء 57 قاضيا وطردهم دون اي تبرير
ودون اتبع الاجراءات القانونيه بل التمادي
في تحدي سلطه القضاء برفض تنفيذ القرار
الاداري باعاده 49 قاضيا من هؤلاء القضاه
المعفين الى اعمالهم كل هذا يؤكد ان
المعركه غير متكافئه
حاله الاحراج التي تعيشها السلطه
التنفيذيه نتيجه حملات المسانده الواسعه
داخل البلاد وخارجها لهؤلاء المعتقلين
السياسيين مهما كانت انتماءاتهم السياسيه
ومواقفهم ومهما كانت خلفيتهم الايديولوجيه
والفكريه في اعلى مستوى اممي عبر المفوضيه
الساميه لحقوق الانسان او مجلس حقوق
الانسان او عبر التمثيليات الدبلوماسيه في
الخارج كل هذا يجعل من السلطه السياسيه في
حاله حرج شديد ربما هو الذي يحول بينها
وبين التوسع في الاعتقالات
[موسيقى]
قطعا
لان
الثقه تكون
بتوفر شروط المحاكمه العادله وخاصه خاصه
بتوفر الشرط الرئيسي واستقلال السلطه
القضائيه والامان القضائي وقدره القاضي
على ان يتخذ قراره دون ان ينتظر تعليمات
من السلطه التنفيذيه ودون ان يخشى على
نفسه ودون ان يخشى ان يمسي مطرودا ومكتبه
مغلق وهذا كله للاسف شديد غير مضمون في
تونس حاليا
[موسيقى]